thank you everyone first of all I want
to say I'm just thrilled about this
award but I really don't deserve it it's
the financial crisis that gets the award
honestly honestly I've been working on
financial markets for many many years
and then all of a sudden this crisis
came along and everybody wanted to hear
about it and the Alumni alumni groups
included had it been let's say a
pandemic or of some sort of like h1n1
you would have seen Larry professor
Larry wine up here or or if it had been
a constitutional crisis you might have
seen Keith Cree bull or Dave Brady up
here but this year it happens to be
financial crisis so I get this award
thank you very much for the award and it
because of it it's my responsibility to
tell you a little bit about what what's
been behind this that is this financial
crisis it's not only my financial it's
not only my responsibility is my great
pleasure because it may not be apparent
to you but it's it's really what
professors love to do is to talk about
their research and this is an area in
which I do research and teaching so what
I want to do is over the next few
minutes leaving plenty of time at the
end for me to hear from your questions
is to kind of lay out that some of the
key events and where they have left us
now short short meaning we have a lot of
work to do to make sure that this
doesn't happen again
or at least if it happens again we will
have at least on our best to make sure
it doesn't happen the way that it
happened this time
and somebody else will we'll take care
of the next one so I'm gonna talk for a
few minutes and then so bigger get your
questions ready because I'm gonna count
on you I'm not going to take up
certainly more than half the time
probably less than half the time so look
the fun part for me at least comes at
the end now as you know about two years
ago a lot of subprime mortgage borrowers
didn't pay back their loans and some
large mortgage financing companies like
countrywide and new century got into
serious trouble
that caused significant losses that
surprisingly didn't really have a big
impact on the stock market or on
investor fear for some time
but then last year as you know things
start to get started to get quite
serious in March the big Investment Bank
Bear Stearns failed due to a run of a
form that I'm going to talk about not a
traditional depositor run that you've
seen photos of during the Depression but
a run of various kinds of capital market
counterparties that I'm going to
describe that's kind of the intellect
content for the today's talk but the
rest of it is color commentary now it's
sort of a scary topic for the end of an
afternoon of an alumni reunion but
anyway there is there is some content
here now as you know the scariest month
of all was September of last year
beginning essentially with the failures
of the two huge mortgage agencies Fannie
Mae and Freddie Mac the government had
to take those over because they were
bust then shortly afterwards
on a weekend Lehman was about to fail
during that same weekend Lehman Brothers
as a fitness a very large 150 year old
investment bank during that same weekend
Merrill Lynch apparently was going to
fail and had to be taken over by the
Bank of America on the morning Monday
morning that Lehman failed declared
bankruptcy there was a run on money
market funds in the United States it's
not a well-known fact but there was
starting with the reserve fund which is
a fund that had invested in Lehman
securities there was an increasing
amount of funds being taken out of money
market accounts around the country and
the Federal Reserve and the Treasury
decided something had to be done and the
government insured money market funds
that week meanwhile it became apparent
that AIG was going to fail AIG being one
of the world's largest insurance
companies the government had to step in
and give eighty five billion dollars
that week to AIG to keep it from
collapsing and possibly bringing down
some of the banks that had relied on it
for insurance that same week rumors
started to circulate that Morgan Stanley
which fortunately did not fail was in
deep trouble because many of its clients
we're leaving in droves and we know now
because the facts are now coming out
that there was a significant loss I'll
describe that in a few minutes of their
ability their ability to finance
themselves in the same way that had
caused Lehman to fail people were even
using the term could Goldman Sachs also
go now we know Goldman Sachs is now one
of the healthiest banks in the world so
although it's been only a few months
it's easy for us to forget what a
serious week that was it was a very
short week but a very severe week later
that month two of the nation's largest
retail banks Wachovia and Washington
Mutual also failed had to be taken over
by the Federal Deposit Insurance
Corporation on September 29th still the
same month Congress was presented a
three-page draft piece of legislation
from Hank Paulson the Treasury secretary
asking for 700 and some billion dollars
to finance a bailout of the financial
industry I remember sitting at my desk
as the votes on the floor of the
Congress came in against that bill and
as they started to be tallying to be
tallied to be tallied in Congress you
could see the Dow Jones average chicking
down vote by vote it dropped 500 points
during the course of that vote on the
House of Representatives eventually as
you know by October first Congress did
pass a version of that Troubled Asset
Relief Program 700 billion dollars of
financing for the financial industry now
after some fits and starts they actually
started to use that money to
recapitalize some of the weakest banks
and later they used some of the same
money for GM and Chrysler and some of
the smaller banks in one week in October
the Dow Jones average lost 22% its worst
ever performance since the Great
Depression and the stock market at that
point was down 40% from its high only a
year ago only a year before stock market
volatility reached the level of 60
percent for sustained periods that had
never done that momentarily in the 1987
stock crash volatility in the stock
market exceeded 60% but for the first
time ever it was sustained at such a
high level that's four times the normal
level of volatility in the stock market
in total stock market investors had lost
globally eight trillion dollars far more
than the losses on subprime mortgages so
this had become a global financial
crisis now since last fall
although the stock market got even lower
thanks to the last resort financing by
the Fed and continued support for the
economy and the financial sector by the
Treasury and by other governments
markets have stabilized earlier this
spring the government tested the banks
in what was called a series of stress
tests announced that they were
satisfactorily capitalized and on that
basis those banks were the weakest banks
were able to raise significant amounts
of capital private capital in capital
markets and that surprised the the
positive effect of that surprised many
including some in the administration
from what I can tell the stock market
subsequently as you know rebounded
stronger housing prices have started to
go back up across the nation they're
still by the way about 50% higher
housing prices in the country are still
about 50 percent higher than they were
in 2001 so maybe this is a good time to
declare this crisis over and look ahead
at our preparations for the next one is
the crisis really over let me ask that
question briefly we're not necessarily
completely out of danger according to
the International Monetary Fund banks
have written off about 1.3 trillion
dollars in bad loans because of the
subprime mortgage related losses but
they still have about 1.5 trillion
dollars
of write-offs on bad loans to go so
there's serious problem in the banking
industry they're continuing to raise
funds but some banks are very weak among
the big banks the ones that are
dangerous to the rest of the financial
system that the too big to fail ones
only Citibank is in deep trouble in my
view but it's on life support from the
federal government which has pumped 45
billion dollars of capital and has
guaranteed the performance of 300
billion dollars of city bank's assets so
Citibank is not going to crash and cause
a big problem but it is as its this is
the kind of bailout that for which we
need to make better preparations we
don't want the government to have to
step in and spend so much taxpayer money
next time we want to be prepared to
allow these large banks to fail without
dire consequences to the rest of the
economy
we still have an unemployment rate of
around 10% which is a post-war high that
is at this sustained level between stowe
between a fragile banking system and a
very weak economic growth for the next
few years positive but very weak I don't
think we're entirely out of trouble but
the most likely path is that we will
continue to recover that we're on a
stable low growth path for some years to
come one might be concerned is in fact
given the run up in the stock market and
the fact that people generally believe
that we managed to get out of this
crisis in reasonable shape what a little
bit worried that people are relying on
the central banks and governments of the
world to fix these crises as they come
up and that we will not fix the
infrastructure of the financial system
so that we don't leave it to chance and
maybe good luck and some smart people
being in the right place at the right
time but rather we just have more robust
financial system the next time around
and what I want to do and this is kind
of the sort of hard core for those of
you that are into hardcore finance is
the hard core part I want to talk about
what we do need to do about keeping
these large dealer banks in a more safe
and sound condition now when I say a
large dealer bank those are banks that
not only may have
Marshall banking services like Citibank
JP Morgan and so on but they also have
businesses making markets in securities
and in derivatives and serving the needs
of hedge funds as clients and doing
asset management for large institutional
investors many I can see are in this
room so these banks are run very large
complex financial businesses but the
point of instability that we discovered
during the financial crisis for banks
like Lehman Bear Stearns the near call
at Morgan Stanley and the other very
large dealer banks I had to do with the
backbone capital market operations in
three areas I'm gonna test you on these
afterwards one area is derivatives I'm
sure most of you have heard about these
not gonna talk about them in detail how
many of you have heard about repurchase
agreements just to get an idea of my
audience all quite a few ok so we got a
pretty sophisticated audience I can race
ahead the that's those are the two of
the areas derivatives and repurchase
agreements which are short-term loans to
these banks that allow them to finance
their securities the third area is
called prime brokerage this is the
business by which these banks handle
securities and cash for hedge funds and
help them execute their trades keep
their accounts provide them with reports
accounting risk management and so on now
these prime brokerage clients are also a
source of instability all three of these
classes of counterparties to these large
dealer banks will rush for the exits
when these banks start to look
distressed and they will accelerate the
onset of a default by these banks just
in the same way if you've seen photos of
depositors lined up during the Great
Depression at a bank that was in trouble
those depositors would line up for cash
because they were afraid that if they
didn't get fast enough into that line
that someone else would get the money
out before they did and by the very act
of withdrawing their money they
accelerated or even caused the failures
of those banks now so as you know in
1933 the government instituted Deposit
Insurance Federal Deposit Insurance
so we don't need to worry in this
country about traditional deposit
insurance run deposit runs on banks but
this is the 21st century we have these
large repo derivatives and prime
brokerage businesses that can run and
when they do they can also do the same
thing they can cause these banks to run
out of cash and not be able to meet
their obligations and fail even if the
banks might in principle be solvent if
you are able to sell all of their assets
in an orderly manner now I want to run
through this very briefly these three
sources first I want to talk about repos
these are very short-term loans
typically overnight by which these large
dealer banks finance their inventories
of securities that they hold for their
own investment and for purposes of
making markets
now if the hint of weakness at one of
these large dealer banks like Lehman
hits the market
anyone that's lending money to Lehman
can simply say why should I continue to
lend money when I could walk away even
if my loan is secured as a repo alone is
by holding securities from Lehman why
would I put myself in a situation where
I have to go through a workout through
bankruptcy I can simply tomorrow lend
that money instead to JPMorgan or some
other Bank now if those short-term
lenders decide not to roll over those
loans then the bank has to find
additional cash financing and its
sources of cash are disappearing at a
time like this it may have to sell
securities into a falling market
sometimes called a fire sale in finance
and that itself can be destructive of
value it can also cause knock-on effects
to the rest of the economy as banks sell
more and more of these troubled assets
the prices get lower and lower and that
causes everybody to get to be in the
same boat so regulators are working on
ways to prevent these runs by repurchase
agreement counterparties that is by
these short-term lenders but they
haven't solved that problem yet now I'm
gonna talk about derivatives
you all have heard about what they are
but you may not be aware that if I enter
into a derivative contract with Bear
Stearns or Lehman or Morgan Stanley that
I must post collateral with them meaning
a cash guarantee that I will perform in
my contract
if I become concerned that one of those
banks may not make it I don't want to
leave myself in harm's way maybe they
won't perform on the derivatives
contract maybe have trouble getting my
cash back so I will take my contract and
move it to another bank a safer bank and
I'll take my cash with me and those
banks will lose a source of financing
and you might say well how will that how
would that cash that I've left there as
collateral be used for the banks by the
banks to finance themselves indeed the
banks are able to use that cash
collateral for their own purposes they
owe it to you but it's not segregated
they can buy other securities lend it to
other customers and so on so by leaving
all mass derivatives counterparties can
reduce the source of cash available to
these large dealer banks this is another
kind of run the third area that I
mentioned is prime brokerage prime
brokerage means as I mentioned earlier
hedge funds or other institutional
investors are provided services by these
large dealer banks and Mason basically
in securities transactions that's the
most important service that they provide
and when a hedge when a hedge fund is
working with Lehman or a Bear Stearns
which were very active in its business
they would typically leave their cash
ins and securities on deposit at the
dealer bank Lehman let's say now in the
United States there are some
restrictions on the ability of Lehman to
use those cash and securities left on
deposit with it by hedge funds there are
some restrictions on the ability of the
of Lehman to reuse that cash and
securities for its own business under
the Securities and Exchange Commission
15 C 3 rules however by a rather arcane
series of transactions there is
nevertheless a substantial source of
funding available when I post my
securities at Lehman it can then lend
them to another investor in the economy
or use them as a collateralized loan to
a certain extent subject to SEC rules
just to give you an idea of the degree
to which a run by prime brokerage
clients could remove your ability to
finance yourself consider the case of
Morgan Stanley now because it survived
we actually have its numbers before and
after of how much securities that were
left with it that it could use to
finance its own business in the report
that it provides before Lehman's fail
nine hundred billion dollars of
securities were left with it by others
that it could use to finance its
business and the first report available
after Lehman failed less than three
hundred billion so a six hundred billion
dollar reduction now doesn't mean six
hundred dollars in cash because in order
to be able to pledge those securities
they had to provide cash to some extent
to their to their hedge fund clients
nevertheless a substantial source of
loss of liquidity because of the
departure of those hedge fund clients
which almost according to some accounts
ruined Morgan Stanley's business if you
read a new book that just came out this
week I got my copy on the first run by
Ross Sorkin your New York Times reporter
called too big to fail or you read his
teaser article a few weeks ago and the
Vanity Fair on the week that Lehman
failed about how Morgan Stanley's
business was suffering from departures
of prime brokerage clients you might be
frightened for example Morgan Stanley
started that week with a hundred and
forty billion dollars of available cash
and it ended the week had thirty billion
dollars of available cash it was going
down twenty billion dollars a day during
some of that week
the United Kingdom it has no
restrictions on the use of securities
and it still doesn't I think that's
something it needs to be fixed and I
think the u.s. rules could also be
tightened up somewhat the derivatives
legislation that needs to be well as you
know there's a series of bills before
Congress right now on how to fix the
over-the-counter derivatives market with
respect to things like clearing which is
guaranteeing that these contracts will
perform by a third party the this
legislation is under tremendous amount
of pressure from both sides some of the
lobbying is improving the legislation
some of the lobbying is not improving
the legislation I've been to Washington
several times in the past year on these
derivatives legislation issues talking
to people in Congress I'm gonna go again
next Wednesday talked to the Senate
Banking Committee and I can tell you
that it's completely unclear right now
how this is going to come out so in the
repurchase agreement area in the
derivatives area and in the prime
brokerage area there is a lot of work to
be done the Obama administration is also
proposed legislation for how to wind up
that is to resolve a failing financial
institution without letting necessarily
letting it go into bankruptcy and the
House Judiciary Committee met yesterday
to debate how that's going to be done
that's still quite up in the air and
there are some serious problems in
getting financial design that allows
these large financial institutions to
wind up their affairs in an orderly
manner
none of the legislation that's been
proposed so far I think is economy is
going to accomplish that I'm making some
proposals and some other economists are
making proposals for a for having a
contractual automatic restructuring of
the balance sheets of these banks when
they become distressed the idea is
there's a bit of fine print on the back
of a bond contract or an equity contract
that says in the event that this large
systemically important financial
institution gets into difficulty hit
this button and for example in the case
of a debt contract the debt obligation
will be replaced we
shares of equity at a certain ratio that
will allow the bank to get recapitalized
without having to go through necessarily
a bankruptcy so I think that's not a
panacea but I think some some thoughtful
non disaster related automatic
restructuring of these financial
institutions could be very very useful
now in all of these areas these are not
going to take care of simple issues of
management I know that any of you that
are not involved in the financial
industry many of you because you came
through Stanford Business School are
heavily involved in management many of
the failures that we saw in the
financial crisis were simply management
problems for example at AIG if you read
the article in Vanity Fair by Michael
Lewis I had a very severe problem with
its senior management and Board of
Directors not understanding the huge
risks that AIG was taking in a very
concentrated of a very concentrated type
if you go to for example Bank of America
one of the nation's largest banks at the
peak of the financial crisis there were
no non management members of the Board
of Directors a Bank of America that had
professional experience in the banking
industry thanked of America as you know
took a lot of risk when it Button
Merrill Lynch and the CEO has now been
slated to leave I think having boards of
directors of large systemically
important financial institutions with
more expertise and Finance might be a
very good idea
now I've mentioned some of the things
that we can do about this sort of a
financial crisis what about the ones
that might happen next
I want to finish on that note what are
they likely to be like well we actually
have a pretty good history there's a
wonderful new book by Carmen Reinhart
and Ken Rogoff on financial crises of
history of financial crises they go back
200 years and it turns out that for the
last 200 years on average the United
States has been in a financial crisis
about one year out of every eight for
the United Kingdom in France the average
is about one year in ten and countries
with very large financial centres like
London or New York tend to have
financial crises more often and it's not
surprising why now the Lord Turner the
head of the United Kingdom's financial
services authority has suggested that
maybe it's not a good idea anymore for
London to be a financial center and that
they should tax financial institutions
so heavily that that there had become
that they reduced the size of their
financial sector I seriously doubt that
that that's the right way to go I think
we want to improve the robustness of the
financial system but not necessarily get
rid of the financial system as we know
it anyway I don't many I bet I don't
many countries would be interested
perhaps except France and getting rid of
their largest financial institutions now
where did the in these last 200 years
where do these financial crises come
from well Carmen Reinhart and Ken Rogoff
find it most often they are associated
with bank losses on real estate loans
neck the next most common causes are
sudden collapses in commodity prices and
with liberalisation of financial markets
regulations so it seems that we had a
few of these things going on those are
the three most common causes we've got
sort of the the the perfect storm or the
mother of all financial crises it seems
so I would certainly start by fixing the
problems that I just
described and we could go back and talk
about the genesis of this crisis and you
know how it was that people took so much
risk and moral hazard and compensation
issues and so on
that's not my message today my message
today is inevitably we're going to get
these crises but we want to make the
plumbing of the financial system much
more robust so that when these losses
occur at one large Bank they don't get
transmitted through the financial system
to other large banks that plumbing needs
to stay relatively clear as I mentioned
the losses in the subprime area were on
the order of a trillion the losses to
the entire global macro economy have
been estimated when the stock market
alone about 10 trillion but more broadly
many more trillion than that as for what
might be completely different next time
well the world is changing we rely a lot
more on electronic infrastructure some
of you may not know that we had a close
call on 9/11 when the bank of New York
which is the one of the two in fact it's
the largest clearing Bank in the world
it handles backboned cash and Treasury
transactions for a large fraction of the
market that went down because it's
electronic telecommunication system was
broken by the attack on the World Trade
Center and there was a close to a panic
in the money markets by which banks fund
each other overnight but that was
averted because the Fed acted very very
expeditiously but we have an increasing
increasingly electronically
interconnected financial system and we
want to pay extra close attention to
security because who's not who knows
maybe that's a an issue that could come
up in the future
another issue that concerns me some to
some extent is that financial crises
tend to happen also at times of major
global currency market instability now
we've had a long run of stability in
that and global currency markets because
the United States has the global
currency the only currency that's
generally accepted in large volumes for
backbone transactions around the world
one of the reasons that the Euro which
is an equally highly demanded currency
for retail purposes is not as a big of a
back
go on currency is that it doesn't have a
single government bond market it has
many different government bond markets
one for each country but the United
States for good or bad has an immense
government bond market and as you know
countries like China and many other
countries use US Treasuries as their
store of value for many for many
purposes so the United States has a kind
of franchise going on on its own
currency gives us a huge advantage but
we can't count on that being there all
the time and if there's enough the next
time that there's a financial crisis if
there isn't a safe haven which is the
u.s. dollar where everyone can go and
Duck and Cover that could be a source of
concern as you know the interest rate
paid on US Treasury bills went negative
during the financial crisis because
everyone wanted to own Treasury bills
and they were off they were willing to
lend money at negative interest rates in
order to get those Treasury bills as a
safe haven now I said I wouldn't go on
too long and I hope I haven't been too
scary but I'd like to open it up to
questions from you all and we can have
some fun discussion maybe you can make a
light a lighter story out of this so
I've got I'll try I guess I'm moderating
this so I'll try to go around are we
gonna use microphones in the audience or
am I just gonna repeat the question
I'll try repeating the question so I'm
gonna start with the gentleman that has
yes basically taken away counterparty
and yes
that's what I was testifying to the
Senate Banking Committee about last
summer there's a thing called a central
clearing counterparty which is exactly
the analog that you spoke of but it
operates in the over-the-counter
derivatives market and it does exactly
what you've proposed instead of me being
at risk to you I would call Dwane and I
would
say Dwayne could you stand in between us
so that if he doesn't pay me you'll
still pay me and if I don't pay you if I
don't pay him you'll still pay him your
joins gonna guarantee our contract
that's what a central clearing
counterparty will do and he'll charge a
fee for it and he'll ask us to post
collateral with him and he'll have
uniform standards and he'll stand in
between these systemically important
financial institutions to make sure that
if one topples over that doesn't bring
the other one with it there's been a
huge debate over the structure of this
market the Congress has decided that it
will favor the placement of
over-the-counter derivatives in those
clearing houses now that will not take
care of an AIG problem the AIG
derivatives were exotic they were
customized and if I called Dwayne and I
said Dwayne I've got these AIG type of
credit derivatives can you handle those
Dwayne would say no that would put me at
risk because I don't know how to price
those on a daily basis and if if I was
to fail if Duffy was to fail Dwayne
would not be in a position to be able to
unwind those positions very easily so I
would put him at risk and that would
because he's systemically important now
that would put us all at risk so that
those central clearing counterparties
can handle the plain vanilla
standardized contracts they can't handle
the others and in my view we shouldn't
kill off the others entirely because
there is a lot of useful customization
that corporations need to do but we
should charge the banks a higher capital
charge if they're going to do those
customized products to make sure that
they have the capital to stand behind
them so that's my answer that sort of a
long answer but that's the answer to
that one now there's a gentleman just
behind the just in front of the video
camera yeah and the white shirt credit
default swaps for AIG would because I
think that a lot of people think they
would have left that along that may have
solved itself but you asked a few people
about that and including some people at
the government and the answer that I got
is if we had had a little more than 24
hours to think about it we could have
done it a lot more cheaply the
government was concerned not so much
about AIG but about the fact that AIG
was offering insurance against subprime
mortgage losses to various banks and it
was concerned those banks would suffer
so much
so with hindsight in fact
very much hindsight the government
should have said we will guarantee those
insurance contracts but we're not going
to guarantee AIG we're gonna cover the
key insurance contracts so maybe we're
gonna lose ten or twenty billion dollars
but we're not gonna lose now it's up to
150 billion dollars now we may get some
of that money back but my guess is we're
gonna lose quite a few more billions and
we needed to have lost and that you know
we didn't have the proper oversight
management corporate governance risk
management and because of that we
weren't prepared and we had to move on
an emergency basis I can understand the
government making some mistakes on an
emergency basis and we just want to make
sure that next time we have more
advanced planning got lots of questions
I'll start with this gentleman right
here with the sweater the question was
what about Paul Volcker's act to reenact
glass-steagall by the way Mervyn King
the governor of the Bank of England has
proposed something very similar I think
it would take care of a lot of the
problems of commercial banks failing
because they're attached to investment
banks like Goldman Sachs or Morgan
Stanley but I don't think it's gonna
cure the problem it would help somewhat
it would also make commerce a little bit
have more friction than I think it
should have so overall I think we can do
better than that it would if it was the
only thing that was available I would go
for it but I think we can do better than
that
in terms of keeping the capital markets
as efficient as possible all of the
measures that have been proposed
including the ones that I have proposed
are going to require more capital to
keep the financial industry going that
means the key financial industry is
going to be more expensive that'll be
able to put it will take more capital to
process the same transactions return on
capital will be lower that will slow
down the economy a little a price we
need to pay but we don't want to in my
view throw capital at every problem
until the point at which the financial
industry is so inefficient that the that
the trade-off goes the other way and
we're losing too much economic growth
because this plumbing is the pipes are
too small basically that's my concern
but as I said it's it's a thoughtful and
and worth worth considering idea the
gentleman here in the black
tshirt right now as the banks strive to
maintain their profitability and the
government is working on consumer
protection ISM how do you see those two
they're conflicting with each other and
how do you see that impacting the
banking business going forward well yeah
as you know the banking industry is
lobbying very hard to prevent the new
Consumer Protection Agency from coming
into place and I have to confess up
until I visited Washington for the last
the last time which was a couple about a
month ago I was against this new
Consumer Protection Agency because the
Fed the OCC the OTS the office of Thrift
Supervision
and the FDIC all have responsibilities
in this area and I thought wow we don't
want another government bureaucracy they
already have this covered and then when
I went to this meeting I was convinced
by a presentation in which it was made
clear that these other agencies have
many conflicting objectives some of
which are in the consumer protection is
not as high on the list as it might be
so now I have become a convert I'm in
favor of adding another federal
bureaucracy to protect consumers from
unsafe or unfair practices by banks now
this one as opposed to what I was
talking about which is systemic risk
this one is in a different area this is
like a drug the FDA protecting you from
getting inappropriate drugs from over
the you know from over the counter or
from retail and so I you know I my views
on this are separate from what I was
saying before but I think it is a good
idea and I think it's a traditional
special interest on the one hand
consumers want their interest protected
on the other hand the banks want to
remain as profitable as possible and
both have good cases to make but I come
down in favor of this consumer
protection agency yes sir in the in the
jacket right here yes the question is
a short of complete failure of two of
the largest banks city and Bank of
America is there a almost middle way in
which the federal government could
restructure take over those two banks
restructure them and give them a brand
new charter to deal only in local state
and federal securities and thereby
secure the capital structure of those
two banks split them up and effect and
make them into much more manageable give
them a regional venue and so on but the
whole competition between Citibank and
Bank of America got to be so vicious
that's why Bank of America stepped out
of line and company it was the egos of
the managers of the owners and CEOs they
cut those two magazines into severe
trouble absent that kind of management
would it be feasible for the federal
government to take them over and
restructure them along the lines I just
suggested well in the case of Citibank
it sounds like your game plan is
essentially you must have given it to
the government because that's roughly
what the government is doing right now
with Citibank they have they have a very
large fraction of the equity of Citibank
and they have been putting pressure on
Citibank to is essentially dismembered
itself selling off any businesses that
it can sell off in order to raise
capital to eventually downsize and focus
on its more and more on its core
confidence I'm not familiar with the
personalities involved but the CEO
former CEO of Citi Chuck Prince indeed
consistent with your the basis of your
question said you know the idea is as
long as the music is play
we continue to dance meaning that if if
we're competing against others and they
are taking on more and more of
businesses that may not be long-run
profitable but we have to do is weld in
order to show that return on our our
accounts and I think that he was
referring to that competition that you
spoke of but I think that kind of
behavior is now at least until our
memories fade and the next crisis comes
along that kind of behavior is not going
to be either tolerated nor nor adopted
in case the Bank of America is quite
different they may have had some some
management problems as I spoke of before
but they're not they haven't been told
by the government that they need to be
dismembered or downsized the government
is waiting to see whether or not they
can come out of this on their own so I
think the government is more in that
case standing on the sidelines yes sir
right here well if I knew that as they
say okay so the question was how do you
measure the formation of bubbles and how
do you foresee the time at which the
bubbles burst I have to tell you I have
to tell you that I find this very very
difficult economists are worse than
anything else at timing so seeing when
they're gonna burst you can forget about
that insert in terms of seeing the
formation of the bubbles whenever you
see very very low costs for borrowing
and you see large capital flows going
from one country like China to another
like the United States watch where the
money goes and probably that asset class
is getting too much investment the risk
premia are shrinking and there's an
encouragement to take more and more risk
now did I see that no but my colleague
at Yale friend of mine Bob Shiller gave
a talk in the room next door actually
room 162 right over there about two
years before the financial crisis and
made a very compelling case that the
price of u.s. real estate have been bid
up to unsustainably high levels relative
to the services offered by housing real
estate in comparison with other measures
like how much does it cost to rent a
house as opposed
by those two numbers are always gonna be
different even in when capital even when
one is capitalized on the same basis as
the other because people like to own
versus rent or vice versa but the ratio
between those two prices had gone
completely out of whack in the previous
five or six years and he was right but
none of nobody else saw it he and only a
few other people were either smart
enough or had spent enough time with the
numbers to actually scope it out and you
know that's that's where fundamental
investing and I know many of you do that
comes in and say you you guys are all
responsible for keeping those prices in
line yes sir liquidity but the more
fundamental one was the valuation and
the leverage in 2004 the SEC changed the
regulation of the leverage available to
the top five dealer brokers by going
from just the ratio of assets to equity
to the sophisticated formulas based on
rating agencies which all know are based
on false statistical analysis today but
you haven't talked about that I picked
up the story after the banks had already
become weakened and I I sort of followed
the entrails to the point of failure
from point of weakness but what caused
them to become weak was as you exactly
as suggested they took too much risk
relative to their capital and that was
allowed particularly among the US
investment banks the European regulators
have been saying all along we don't
think that Bear Stearns Lehman Goldman
Sachs and Morgan Stanley are properly
their capital is sufficient and the SEC
said as you suggested well we have these
capital requirements and Hank Paulson
testified to Congress the week before
Lehman failed literally the week before
Lehman failed and Chris Cox the head of
the SEC testified before Congress
literally the week before even failed
that they had adequate capital and it
was Chris Cox's responsibility and I
actually met with him recently he was
very honest and straightforward he said
oh that was the best numbers we had but
obviously they weren't good enough so
these are the way that these numbers are
kept is insufficient you know it's not
adequate we need proper mark-to-market
accounting and we need much tighter
controls on leverage
well the you know and I want to repeat
is that a lot of mistakes are going to
get made and these banks are even if we
fix the leverage problem they're going
to get into trouble the next time my
concern that is the area in which I'm
focusing my remarks today and in fact
most of my research and working in
Washington now is on once they get into
trouble try to prevent their failure
from creating a knock-on effect that
will clog the plumbing of the financial
system and cause a macroeconomic
recession but I don't think we can do
the best we can to prevent them from
taking too much risk but I don't think
we're gonna be able to foresee or look
around corners and see how they might be
able to do that the next time we want to
allow them to fail not bail them out and
prevent that from getting hit the next
place but you're absolutely right yes
sir with the glasses the tall man right
here commercial real estate business
serious problem as I mentioned the
International Monetary Fund as this has
estimated an additional 1.5 trillion
dollars in loan losses still to be
written down that's including five
trillion right around here
but globally globally there's a lot more
that's going to happen fortunately we're
not in the middle of a financial crisis
it should be possible for the banks to
recapitalize as they go and to use the
earnings that they're making you know
some banks are quite profitable now like
JP Morgan and Goldman as you may have
read are just raking in money other
banks are doing okay and they'll be able
over time to cover these losses I had a
conversation with Ben Bernanke when I
was in Washington a few months ago about
about this issue and he said you know
it's not always the case that the assets
of a bank are worth more than their
liabilities although we always learn in
the accounts that that's supposed to be
the that's supposed to be true they
often find themselves underwater but in
the normal course of affairs they can
work that out
and that's that's why you know the Fed
is there to pump up the economy and keep
them going and lower interest rates so
they can more make more profits when
when they're in desperate trouble but we
but again in a financial crisis that
doesn't work because there's a run on
the bank
and we find out that the assets are
worth less than the liabilities because
we actually liquidate both sides of the
balance sheet and just there's not
enough to cover the the liabilities wait
and see that's right and I and I'm
relatively optimistic so I'm not telling
a scary story on that front yes sir well
it has swung these off-balance sheet
conduits have been cut yeah oh sorry the
the gentleman has asked me what about
off-balance sheet financing conduits for
the large banks like Citibank which had
a lot of it and now that we are in a
situation where we understand that these
are dangerous I think that's the premise
will the pendulum swing to the other
direction and instead of having too much
leverage will would be too conservative
which is in principle a danger because
you know if you require too much capital
for to make a loan then it'll be too
expensive for people to borrow to buy
you know to borrow on their credit cards
to get to buy homes to buy cars for
factories to hire workers you know
we don't want to slow down the economy
to zero by restricting the availability
of credit we need to allow some degree
of flexibility to the financial system
so my view on that is the government
doesn't need to worry at this point
about too much about its desire to
reduce leverage at the banks the banks
have already taken care of that to a
great extent they become very
conservative in the way that they're
making loans they no longer have these
off-balance-sheet financing conduits
there are no longer there is no longer a
business which is called securitization
it's essentially disappeared for the
time being so very few loans are being
made in the well I might take issue with
that it could it could come back in a
good way
but there's many fewer loans voluntarily
the financial industry is making very
few loans relative to its capital
compared to what it was a few years ago
now eventually the government if they do
start to roll up they leverage again the
government is gonna have to step in and
and make sure that they don't roll it up
too fast but I don't think we need to to
worry about the government putting the
brakes on too hard maybe the financial
industry has to has to figure out how to
get more efficiency on its own for the
time being okay I've got a gentleman
back here with I can't I can't read
anything on your name card
I'm confused by which sheet when you're
talking about the banking system what is
the banking system and you take the
regulated banks as I understand it only
about 25 what is the banking system sure
about 25 years ago the ratios were
reversed from what you said the banking
system was about 2/3 of lending
according to the flow of funds
information from the government but now
it's about 1/3 of lending and the rest
of it is what's called a shadow banking
system which is what you're referring to
these are non-bank conduits for getting
credit to consumers homebuyers factories
private equity hedge funds and it
happens through many different kinds of
vehicles the most important of which in
terms of volume was securitization which
allowed banks to originate loans but not
continue to be the lender but rather
passed a loan to another investor in a
package which is quite complicated
called a collateralized debt obligation
and that business was as you know at the
very core of the cause of the financial
crisis and again because continuing the
theme of my answer to a previous
question I'm taking it from there in my
study to the disaster in the dealer
banks but you're absolutely right we
need to fix that system as well in fact
the private industry I think is going to
fix that industry has disappeared for
now securitization is there's no
issuance for now except where it's
supported by central banks particularly
the ECB and the Fed but on the private
side it's just going to start dribbling
out new collateralized debt obligations
again and I think it's good if it's done
well and it looks like it's gonna be
done much better we don't have to worry
about them making too many wild and
reckless loans now because investors
don't want those kinds of shadow banking
collateralized debt obligations very
much now they have to be done very
safely in order to
tract investors there's going to be
improved transparency standards there's
a system that's that's come into place
in the in the residential
mortgage-backed securities market for
improved transparency there are some
ratings issues we could talk about
another day long complicated story but I
think that industry is going to come
back in a much much healthier and safer
way and then it'll be another 20 or 30
years at least before it gets us into a
very serious problem again
yes right next door yes gentlemen
listening to you I had the impression
that what went wrong was that people in
charge had the bad judgment they were
taking too much risk and part of the
answer to that I heard was well their
regulation to prevent them from making
mistakes that in itself bothers me maybe
maybe it's two questions but I'm going
further okay go ahead and that now back
of years ago the Enron scandal led to
the demise of Arthur Andersen and I
don't think I think about a dozen people
were in grade when AIG financial
products was guaranteeing banks to the
tune of tens of billions without making
adequate provisions is that just bad
judgment
all right first of all I agree with the
premise of your question there's no way
that we're gonna pass regulations for
smarter managers better managers more
diligent managers nothing that I've
suggested would have the government go
in and say one individual is not
qualified another individual is better
or you'd better shape up and be smarter
the government is not going to be
effective of that it's the same thing as
trying to outlaw fear and greed it's not
going to be an effective thing to pass a
rule to say that investors shouldn't be
afraid or they shouldn't be greedy what
we need is a sound system of financial
infrastructure we need the plumbing the
valves the pipes the joints the tubes
all have to be very robust safe big
diameter they can take big gushes of
risk of capital flows without breaking
and if one of them breaks it's not going
to bring down all of the rest but that's
that's what I'm personally working very
hard for any area of derivatives for
example these clearing houses of the
gentleman up here was speaking about in
the area of repurchase agreements I'm
proposing a utility which would be just
like an ATM machine you stick in your
securities you get out your cash there's
no discretion and you have to put in the
right amount of securities per unit of
cash so these are not rules that the
government is going to impose on
managers to say please be smarter or
don't be evil because that's not good
that's not what the government does well
and it's not effective but rather
infrastructure that's what I'm all about
yeah I'll gentleman right over here
you mentioned the conservative
conservative nature of banks the lack of
securitization I'm involved with and you
know part of their structures they've
got many of those are healthy companies
but they can't get the credit so they're
not only being hit by the general
economy consumer confidence that's the
common question is interestingly I have
a PhD student who just left and has now
taken a job at Boston College who's done
research on the as you move from
recession to growth period in the
economy how banks tighten and loosen
their lending standards now this is not
just they charge more interest rate or
less interest rate they actually
restrict credit more during recessions
than during expansions and he's shown
quite conclusively that that exacerbates
the losses because it's at the peak when
you're providing loans freely now you're
building up this immense quantity of
debt that's going to have very low
recovery in the event of a recession so
the story that you told is not just the
companies that you've witnessed it's in
fact very common across the economy and
in fact bankers are are pulled by the
government periodically I think it's
either monthly or quarterly for how
conservative their lending standards are
now this is subjective a subjective poll
but nevertheless they're also consistent
with exactly what you described them so
if you want to know when this is going
to end wait until we have some more
economic growth the banks are a little
more flush with capital and then you'll
see lighter lending standards and let's
hope it doesn't go too much beyond that
that they'll adopt not as weak lending
standards eventually as they did in 2004
and 2005 thank you very very much for
the opportunity